once the end of the line for branch of
Oregon's railroad prineville has become
a new spoke in the information
superhighway everything that's going on
in the world related to Facebook come
through a data center all those photos
videos and updates that hundreds of
millions of users throw up on Facebook
every day a stored on servers in vast
buildings like this known as data
centers this is Facebook's most
efficient data center to date and is in
prineville that's due in large part to
the climate of Central Oregon so the
space of 10 this is the air intake room
we call the penthouse of the data center
space here in the high desert so whether
it's hot or cold it's very very dry air
on a cold day this dry air is used to
cool the service directly in the
summertime the warmer outside air is
forced through giant damp membranes to
cool it before it circulated the power
requirements and electric bills can be
enormous in data centers like this but
in prineville the naturally dry air
helps cut costs prineville resident
Karen hacker monitors and replaces any
problematic servers in this naturally
air-conditioned environment for people
surprise do you think when when someone
said I'll you know Facebook's moving to
prineville a large company like facebook
i think it was definitely a shock and
now Apple has gone to town building a
338 thousand square foot facility just
up the road from facebook and there was
another big incentive for both Facebook
and Apple we told them that we could
give them 15 years of tax free on the
improvements that they put on the land
we've had people in our community say to
us you gave it away what do you say to
that and I say no we did it when it
becomes a taxable entity in 15 years
they're not only paying taxes on the
land but they are going to be paying
taxes on a huge such a huge facility
those tax revenues may eventually run
into the millions of dollars in this
town that's still in need of a boost
this is what's going to be the new grade
school mayor rope a hopes this kickstart
will help revitalize prineville and
serve as an example but other small town
and follow